[Music]
this august apple became the most
valuable publicly traded company in the
world
overtaking aramco as its market cap
soared past two trillion dollars for the
first time ever
and that is a two trillion dollar
milestone
shares of the company increased to
nearly 60 percent this year
i mean it really is history but the
company's road to 2 trillion dollars
hasn't been a straight climb
after founder steve jobs passed away in
2011
many investors doubted that his
successor tim cook
could fill his shoes and propel the
company forward
really a trillion dollar market cap
wasn't part of the discussion back then
it was much more about whether tim cook
could even sustain
the level of success that they'd had but
amidst lawsuits regulatory
investigations and an ongoing trade war
apple's shares have surged this is how
apple became the most valuable publicly
traded company in the world
introducing apple ii the easy to operate
home computer
apple first launched its apple ii home
computer in 1977
revolutionizing the industry and the
world but to follow its rise to the very
top
a good place to start is august 2018
when apple reached its one trillion
dollar market cap for the first time
ever
surpassing other tech giants by billions
of dollars
apple is now as valuable as the four
biggest u.s banks combined and if you'd
put
ten thousand dollars in apple in 1980
today
you'd be a millionaire the company was
coming off one of its strongest years
since the death of steve jobs
applet had some stumbles up through 2016
and there were doubts about tim cook's
leadership
and the company's products prospects in
its in in the china market things
started to stabilize really uh
later that year and in 2017 and by 2018
i think people had a sense
that the company was really clicking
again the iphone 10 had come out and you
saw the stock just continued to rise and
rise and rise and then
in the middle of 2018 it kind of shot up
to get over the
milestone in july 2018 the company
reported its best
third quarter ever its flagship iphones
remained
widely popular and sales from the app
store and other services had hit
all-time highs but this wasn't going to
last
about a month later apple released a new
suite of iphones
which included its most expensive model
yet
this is iphone 10s
it is the most advanced iphone we've
ever created
they were riding high in 2018 going into
the launch of the new phones later that
year
they were sounding very confident that
those phones would succeed
but things didn't go as expected in
january 2019 apple announced it had
missed its expectation for iphone sales
this had a lot to do with the ongoing
trade war between the us
and china the chinese economy was
suffering and
purchases of iphones in china fell
sharply the higher
priced phone i think people felt
underwhelmed by the new features and
questioned whether it was worth spending
that much in response the company
slashed its quarterly revenue forecast
for the first time
in over 15 years since its peak the
company lost more than 400 billion
dollars in market value
2018 turned out to be apple's worst
yearly stock performance since the
financial crisis
and for some skeptics this fall from
grace seemed to confirm their doubts
that tim
cook would successfully lead the company
then in march 2019 cook moved to
dramatically expand a strategy the
company started in 2017.
today we're excited to extend our
services
even further making them even more
entertaining
more useful and more informative during
a special event in cupertino california
the company announced the apple credit
card apple tv
plus and a number of new finance gaming
and new services
this is something that had already been
set in motion before and that tim cook
had really been hammering on for a
couple years at that point
and it was really part of an effort to
transform the company from being
focused on gadgets to being focused on
gadgets and the services
that attach themselves to those gadgets
amid press around the event
apple's stock price continued to rise
the company's big bet on services was
starting to pay off
in the spring of 2019 the u.s china
trade war was gathering
momentum donald trump was threatening
and imposing
new tariffs and there was a great
concern for apple that
its iphones and other gadgets could get
more expensive for us consumers as a
consequence of this
for years trump has pressured apple to
move more of its production
to the us and that was something that
really wasn't feasible on a mass scale
for apple in fact
around this time they were planning to
shift manufacturing
of the one product that they were still
making in the us
over to china and that was their highest
end mac desktop
computer cook was able to largely
navigate around the tariffs and avoid
having much damage to apple as a
consequence with key products such as
iphones exempted from sanctions
apple stock continued to gain momentum
but amid a surge of growth
apple's new focus on services brought
scrutiny from federal regulators
in the u.s the company faced anti-trust
probes related to its app store
where many of the services are based but
this didn't seem to phase investors
over the course of the year apple has
bought back around 80 billion dollars
worth of its own shares
further juicing the stock price and by
january 3rd
the company's share price had more than
doubled from the year before
apple's future looked promising and then
this happened chinese authorities have
traced a new deadly virus back to this
seafood market in the city of uhan
the coronavirus has spread to countries
across the world severe border
restrictions and global share market
free falls
are testing our politics economies and
society
as the coronavirus pandemic spread
across the world
apple's manufacturing hubs in china were
hit especially hard
like most companies apple stock
in in february of this year the
coronavirus was
scaring investors and apple was probably
more exposed to it than most companies
because it emanated from china
apple's contract manufacturers in china
had to close their factories for a time
as they dealt with the coronavirus
impact but apple's stock quickly bounced
back
in the u.s the federal reserve enacted a
colossal stimulus plan
to pump cash into the economy lifting
the markets including stocks like apple
and as people's lives changed technology
became even more essential there's a
whole working from home thing going for
you
during the pandemic period people were
at home they had to work and their
children had to use computers or tablets
to be able to go to school people
weren't didn't have any other
entertainment other than what they could
do at home so they were watching more
tv programming and streaming music and
downloading apps
all that benefited apple on july 30th
apple released an earnings report that
highlighted an 11 percent increase in
revenue
in april we expected year-over-year
performance to worsen
but we saw better than expected demand
in may
and june we attribute this increase in
demand to several
interactive causes including a strong
iphone se launch continued economic
stimulus
following the news apple shares
continued to balloon
and on august 19th the company reached a
2 trillion dollar market cap for the
first time ever
becoming the most valuable publicly
traded company in the world
at this point you people would bet
against apple's ability to execute
but at the same time it's no guarantee
the stock's going to keep going up the
way it has
apple faces a number of significant
challenges on the regulatory front
it's a subject of antitrust
investigations in the u.s and europe
it's also at war with a number of
companies that are criticizing it over
its business practices in the app store
and elsewhere
and it's more exposed than probably any
other american company to the us
china trade wars in the midst of a
volatile market
apple shares continue to see big swings